[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: Building
interoperability
across systems in health
care poses unique challenges,
especially if they are siloed.
This is where the health
care API helps accelerate
the uploading, sending,
analyzing, storing,
and interfacing with
other health care
data via cloud-based
applications.
And so in this episode,
we will talk about
what is a health care API?
And what are some best
practices around using FHIR?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
API stands for Application
Programming Interface
and is a kind of library
of functions that passes
information over the web.
It defines the inputs and
outputs available over HTTP.
The health care API specifically
bundles multiple tools
and processes that help
application developers deliver
compliance in a heavily
regulated environment,
as well as store sensitive
patient information
in a more convenient
and standard manner.
And even though
you enable it like
you do with any other API
in the Google Cloud console,
the health care API contains
specialized data-storing
modalities in order to support
DICOM, HL7v2, and FHIR.
DICOM means Digital Imaging
and Communications in Medicine,
and we will talk more about
that in another episode.
Next is HL7v2, which is an
event messaging service that
was created in 1989 for
health care entities
to communicate with each other--
such as medical providers,
labs, insurers, et cetera.
Now, there are two common
challenges, however.
The first is that it's
semi-structured data,
and that is difficult to parse.
And the second is that it
uses a protocol that predates
the internet's HTTP standard.
To overcome these,
the health care
API can store the
messages in its raw format
or parse the messages
for developers
to more easily work with it.
And one can overcome the
protocols web constraints
by also using a free
adapter in tandem
with the health care API.
Doing this also then expands
your ability to leverage
additional Cloud
infrastructure tools,
which can help process
massive amounts of data
to find insights or
apply machine learning.
Next, moving on to FHIR, which
stands for Fast Health Care
Interoperability Resources.
This is an API and data
standard that came about
as the industry has been
working on improving
the exchange of
electronic health records
by leveraging modern web-based
technologies like OAuth, JSON,
and HTML.
The health care
API has the benefit
of mapping data as a graph
or a web of resources
that are interconnected, and
you can perform human queries
over them.
Let's take a quick look.
SPEAKER 2: On top of a robust
set of API functionalities,
the health care team has
built a user interface
to interact with Google
Cloud's health care API.
Here I am looking at the Dataset
view, a way for organizations
to logically partition
their resources.
If I click in, I
have the ability
to create data stores
right within the interface.
Data stores can include
Consent, DICOM, HL7, and FHIR.
When creating a FHIR store,
I can attach a Cloud Pub/Sub
topic for triggering
downstream workflows.
This will essentially fire off
when there are any changes made
to the back-end database.
I can also attach a label
for use cases like billing
and choose which version of
FHIR I would like to utilize.
Back in the Dataset
view, I have the ability
to import, export to both Google
Cloud Storage and BigQuery,
de-identify my data, delete,
or open up into a FHIR viewer.
This FHIR viewer is
a interface to be
able to see the data and
interact with the data
without directly invoking
the back-end API.
We can see, our
resources are listed.
And I'll be searching for
the Encounter resource.
This is listing all
of the encounters
I have within my FHIR store.
If I click in, we can see
there's an Overview, Elements,
and JSON tab.
The Elements is a
logical representation
of the raw JSON object.
We still have the
ability to view it
as a JSON object if your
developers would prefer.
Within Elements, each
of these is a dropdown.
So for example, when
looking at reasonCode,
we can see there's a snomed code
associated with this encounter.
We also have the
ability to check things
like referential
integrity, which
is the ability to refer
to another resource
in the FHIR store.
This is currently telling me
this practitioner was the owner
or who saw the person
within this encounter.
We can click the practitioner
and actually go view their data
in the dataset.
So not only do we a robust
set of implementations
within the FHIR API, we also
have developer-friendly tools
to better leverage the product.
FHIR's been getting a lot
of buzz in the market today
due to its promise in
interoperability and US
legislation changes.
One of the main benefits that
we see in organizations that
move towards a
FHIR-based data model
is the ability to unlock
real-time use cases.
Google's FHIR server is
built on the same technology
that Cloud Spanner is
built on and run on.
Thus, this allows for high
transactions and throughput,
both necessary things for
AI analytics use cases.
One of the biggest
considerations an organization
should make when adopting
a FHIR-based standard
is how well it scales.
Ideally, a FHIR store
should be able to hold
all an organization's
data without a large loss
in performance.
That's one of the best
things about managed products
and Google Cloud's FHIR API.
It will automatically
scale to meet your workload
and your data storage needs.
That way, an
organization can use it
for any number of use
cases without having
a need for data replication
or bringing latency
into their applications.
SPEAKER 1: To learn more, visit
cloud.google.com/healthcare.
And to get started,
you will need
to have a Google Cloud project.
If you do not have one, I have
included a link to a trial
account with free credits
in this video subscription,
along with other
helpful resources.
And community, if you
found this episode helpful,
you can subscribe to the
channel to get notifications
of more health care episodes.
Cheers.
[MUSIC PLAYING]